comment tester si un médicament un effet
si un pesticide et cancérigènes ou cd
utilisateurs aiment une mise à jour d'un
site web
dans tous ces cas les scientifiques
s'accordent généralement à dire qu'il
existe un standard ultime de la méthode
scientifique à appliquer à savoir les
tests randomisée en double aveugle
aujourd'hui on parle de ce que beaucoup
considère être la science sous sa forme
la plus idéale avant d'aller plus loin
arrêtons nous sur ce schéma a tirés de
wikipédia
j'imagine que vous l'avez déjà plus ou
moins croisés il décrit la méthode
scientifique telle qu'elle est le plus
souvent présentés selon ce schéma en
tout cas la méthode scientifique se
décompose en quatre étapes théorie
prédictions expériences et observations
pour mieux comprendre le monde cette
méthode scientifique consiste alors à
répéter ces étapes
on aimait une théorie on détermine une
prédiction de la théorie on conçoit une
expérience pour tester la théorie on
effectue l'expérience dont on tire une
observation
puis il rejette où on a juste la théorie
en fonction de l'observation et on
recommence alors dit comme ça ça peut
paraître simple cependant il ya en fait
plein de pièges potentiels dans cette
démarche notamment ici là là et là aussi
bon en fait à toutes les étapes du
processus en particulier ici il ya le
problème de la fameuse paix value est le
noeud de contention entre fréquentes
east et bayésiens mais ça on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir
ce sur quoi je vais m'arrêter
aujourd'hui c'est cette étape ici à
savoir la conception d'expériences et en
particulier on va voir pourquoi les
sciences privilégie les tests dits
randomisée en double aveugle
imaginons que je veuille tester
l'efficacité éducatif d'une vidéo de la
chaîne youtube one rida hashtag abonnez
vous on pourrait se dire que pour y
arriver il suffit de prendre un groupe
d'étudiants de les faire passer un
premier test puis de les faire regarder
une vidéo ou un dida puis de les faire
passer un second test est a priori on
envie de dire que s'ils font mieux au
second test c'est que la vidéo un dida a
fonctionné sauf que non en fait ce qui
est probable a priori c'est que les
étudiants améliorent leurs performances
même si la vidéo wanted a n'a pas été
instructive en tant que tel
on peut en effet avancé diverses raisons
pour penser cela mais typiquement le
premier test a peut être entamé une
réflexion chez les étudiants qui les a
fait progresser et c'est peut-être ça
qui leur a permis de mieux réussir le
second test
on peut aussi imaginer que les étudiants
mettent du temps à se mettre en marche
et qui en font une sorte d'échauffement
ou call inverse ils seront fatigués au
moment de passer le second test pour
éviter tous ces billets potentiel dans
l'analyse à venir quand ils le peuvent
les scientifiques vont alors introduire
un groupe de contrôle aussi appelé
groupe témoin cet autre groupe va subir
la même expérience que le groupe test à
l'exception de ceux que l'on cherche à
tester à savoir ici l'effet d'une vidéo
wanted a en gros c'est une façon de
mettre en pratique la phrase toutes
choses égales par ailleurs l'analyse des
résultats de l'expérience consistera
ensuite à une comparaison entre les
résultats du groupe tests et ceux du
groupe contrôle et d'ailleurs ce que je
décris là est plus ou moins la thèse de
derek miller de la chaîne veritas yom
qui on parle très bien dans cette vidéo
que je recommande vivement
dans le cas des remèdes c'est à dire des
solutions pour ramener une chose ou une
personne à son état habituel
l'utilisation du groupe de contrôle est
d'autant plus important à cause
notamment de ce qu'on appelle la
régression à la moyenne civiquement s'il
s'agit d'améliorer les notes et des
moins bons étudiants au premier test
alors il sera d'autant plus important
d'utiliser un groupe de contrôle car ces
étudiants qui se sont ratés aux premiers
tests ont peu de chance de tout autant
rater le second idem quand il s'agit de
médicaments ou de performances de pilote
d'avion
je vous renvoie vers cette excellente
vidéo de veritas y sommes pour en savoir
plus quand il s'agit de tester l'effet
d'une action pour rétablir une situation
anormale
un groupe de contrôle est indispensable
pour bien analyser les résultats d'une
expérience car dans ce cas il faut
s'attendre à un rétablissement de la
situation anormale
même en l'absence de toute action
cependant faire une expérience avec un
groupe de contrôle ça ne suffit
absolument pas pour éviter des erreurs
dans l'analyse des résultats
c'est l'occasion d'en revenir à mon
exemple de football que je vous invite à
aller voir maintenant si ce n'est pas
déjà fait car je vais un peu ce pôle est
le paradoxe de simpson qui est présenté
pour tester l'impact d'un joueur de
football disons ngolo quand est on peut
imaginer comparer les performances de
l'équipe de france avec et sans compter
il s'agirait là d'une expérience avec un
groupe de contrôle
en effet on comparerait bien l'équipe de
france avec quand est ce qui correspond
au groupe tests avec l'équipe de france
50 et ce qui correspond au groupe de
contrôle cependant j'espère que ça fait
tilt dans votre tête et que vous
comprenez pourquoi une telle comparaison
seraient insuffisantes pour conclure de
manière définitive
en particulier il reste possible que
kanté est un impact positif mais que
l'équipe de france est de moins bons
résultats avec kant et que son compte et
je vous invite d'ailleurs à mettre pause
pour réfléchir à comment c'est possible
et oui le problème ce sont les possibles
facteurs de confusion qui sont la cause
du paradoxe de simpson
en effet il est possible que pour
préserver quand et didier deschamps ne
fasse jouer quand et que contre de très
grosses équipes comme l'allemagne ou le
brésil la france pourrait toujours
gagner sans compter car ces matches sans
kanté sont des matches contre le
luxembourg où le liechtenstein et elle
fera du coup moins bien avec kant et non
pas parce que quand elle joue mal mais
parce que les matches avec kant et sont
des matches contre des grandes équipes
or comme on l'a vu dans la série sur
l'ir de tel paradoxe de simpson sont
omniprésents quand il s'agit de données
observationnelles il faut alors toujours
suspecté c'est horrible facteurs de
confusion
et ce n'est pas parce qu'on n'arrive pas
à les identifier qu'il n'existe pas un
homme en particulier compris ceux ci
mieux que n'importe qui d'autre
à savoir le très grand ronald fischer
fischer se rendit compte que ce paradoxe
de simpson demeurait y compris pour des
expériences en laboratoire
pourvu que la conception des groupes
tests et groupe de contrôle était
l'aboutissement d'une sélection qu'elle
soit humaine ou naturelle typiquement
s'il ya une règle ou un expérimentateur
qui choisissent ils tel sujet il ira
dans le groupe teste où le groupe
contrôle alors cette règle ou 7
expérimentateurs sera un potentiel
facteurs de confusion pour éviter tout
facteur de confusion
il faut interdire toute sélection
potentiel au moment d'assigner un
individu au groupe tests ou au groupe
contrôle et l'astuce de fisher pour
garantir l'absence de sélection et l
utilisation du hasard randomisés 10 est
il souvent
et en effet il n'y a rien d'aussi
efficace que l'aléatoire pour supprimer
tous facteurs de confusion
c'est un cirque n'acquiert les
expériences dit contrôler et randomisés
en anglais on parle de vol dommages
contrôle km/uh
art city les rct s'est souvent considéré
comme étant le standard ultime de la
méthode scientifique
c'est ce qui permet d'obtenir des
résultats qui permettent de conclure
sans craindre c'est horrible facteurs de
confusion alors pas tout à fait le
risque qui demeure avec les airs cité
notamment lorsqu'elle sujet d'étude sont
humains c'est le fait que les humains
réagissent potentiellement davantage à
l'information
je suis dans le groupe teste où je suis
dans le groupe contrôle qu'ils ne
réagissent à l'objet de l'expérience
voilà qui est particulièrement le cas en
médecine ou le très connu l'effet
placebo fait que les patients guérissent
bien mieux lorsqu'ils pensent être prise
en charge
je vous invite à aller voir l'une de ces
vidéos qui en parle pour éviter de
mesurer l'effet placebo plutôt que
l'effet d'un médicament
les scientifiques favorise donc
l'expérience en double aveugle il doit
être impossible pour un sujet de savoir
s'il a fait partie du groupe tests ou du
groupe contrôle mais ce n'est pas tout
de nombreuses études montrent que les
responsables de l'expérience traite
souvent différemment les sujets des
groupes tests et contrôles et ce de
manière inconsciente
un médecin sera peut être plus
enthousiastes avec un patient du groupe
tests tandis qu'un vidéaste qui est
derrière la chaîne - dida poids
davantage motiver les étudiants qui ont
vu la vidéo en dinars est chouette et le
truc c'est que ceci peut avoir lieu de
manière consciente ou de manière
inconsciente je vous renvoie vers
l'effet pygmalion dont j'ai parlé dans
cette vidéo et auquel sens étonnante a
dédié un billet de blog
nous sommes très mauvais pour juger du
rôle de notre inconscient pour éviter de
mesurer l'effet des expérimentateurs
le standard ultime des sciences lorsque
les sujets sont humains ou animaux est
alors le test randomisés contrôlés en
double aveugle
cette fois à la fois les sujets et les
expérimentateurs ne seront pas quel
sujet appartient à quel groupe au cours
de l'expérience
enfin at-on un protocole qui
implémentent vraiment la phrase toutes
choses égales par ailleurs les résultats
de ce protocole pourront bel et bien
être analysées sans craindre les
facteurs de confusion
donc si je récapitule
le test randomisés contrôlés en double
aveugle c'est un test dont le but est de
supprimer tout biais potentiels dont
l'analyse en particulier la régression à
la moyenne les facteurs de confusion et
les effets de placebo pour y arriver il
propose de prendre un ensemble de sujets
et de le diviser aléatoirement en deux
groupes un groupe contrôle et un groupe
teste le groupe teste recevra l'action
que l'on mesure le groupe contrôle ne
recevra rien et de façon cruciale pour
que tous soient comparables
il faut que tout sujet et tout
expérimentateurs ignore si le sujet
reçoit ou non l'action en question
grâce à ce protocole très ficelé on
pourra obtenir des données de haute
qualité qui pourront être analysés sans
bémol liées aux facteurs de confusion en
particulier les scientifiques proposent
ensuite souvent d'analyser les résultats
avec une méthode simple est devenu ultra
standard à savoir la méthode par p value
et si cette méthode par p va lui
fonctionne alors on aura une méthode
scientifique qui roule
elle aussi sauf que spoiler alert la
paix value ne fonctionne pas si bien que
ça mais on y viendra
mais la paix valliot n est en fait pas
la seule critique à faire
malheureusement en pratique les tests
randomisés contrôlés en double aveugle
ça coûte cher comme vous l'avez compris
ça nécessite beaucoup de précautions et
ça ne permet donc pas de générer
d'énormes quantités de données
par ailleurs ça nécessite de recruter et
de s'occuper de beaucoup de sujets
animaux ou humains voire de leur
administrer des traitements dont on ne
sait pas encore les effets niveau
éthique c'est pas tout rose
qui plus est on peut fortement douter de
la généralise à billy t des tests
randomisés contrôlés en double aveugle
dans l'environnement très artificielle
du laboratoire voire même de la
reproductibilité d'un laboratoire de
recherche à l'autre enfin et surtout les
tests randomisés contrôlés en double
aveugle ne permettent de répondre qu'à
des questions qui permettent d'être
répondu par des tests randomisés
contrôlés en double aveugle
or à bien y réfléchir la plupart des
questions dignes d'intérêt ne sont pas
nécessairement de la sorte
toutes ces critiques mais très bien sûr
d'être développé bien plus longuement
dans des épisodes dédiés
rassurez vous c'est prévu mais spoiler
alert
le fait de parler en anglais de grands
dommages de contrôle
11 c'est à dire d'ivoire le tribunal où
se décident les vérités scientifiques
ça me semble extrêmement fallacieux et
contreproductif la nar fois je vous ai
posé la question de casque une
probabilité et citron meerab a fourni
une réponse de mathématiciens pur c'est
vraiment la réponse qu'il était attendue
entame en haleine s qui s'appuie sur la
théorie de la mesure où l'idée c'est de
dire que la probabilité d'un événement
correspond à une espèce de fonctions
mathématiques qui a tout sous ensembles
d'un ensemble très très grand sumu
rappeler aux médias cette mesure
associée à tous ensemble une probabilité
un nombre entre 0 et 1 et qui plus est
il faut que cette fonction satisfasse
certaines propriétés comme par exemple a
dit tivité des probabilités de
sous-ensembles disions alors ça c'est
une approche très en soliste et très
bourbaki ce que j'ai envie de dire je
pense qu'on peut voir plus simplement
avoir des axiomes un petit peu plus
faible sur les probabilités et
considérer qu en fait une probabilité si
une fonction sur ce qu'on appelle une
civ m'hadjeb dire que l'on va d'abord
considérer un ensemble d'événements et
un ensemble d'opérations sur ces
événements notamment par exemple la
négation d'un événement et puis tout ce
qu'on peut faire en utilisant des
connecteurs logique et où
et puis on va supposer qu'il ya
certaines propriétés par rapport à tout
ça par an par exemple la distribution
vite et du et par rapport aux voilà
quelques opérations algébrique qu'on
s'autorise donc là on parle de sigma
algèbre et ensuite une probabilité
ça correspond à une fonction qui va de
la cigm algèbre vers l'ensemble 0 1 et
qui satisfait quelques propriétés comme
par exemple la loi de la probabilité
d'un et dont on a d'ailleurs déjà parlé
dans l'épisode de daniel pose la
question lui de qu'en est il de la
proche banlieue end à la prod by then
consiste à calculer la formule de pays à
considérer du coup un ensemble de
théories est à voir à quel point ces
différentes théories qui sont
généralement très complexe j'ai
rencontré les théories très complexe
notamment si on a des données empiriques
et qui sont du coup très compliqué le
bazin va chercher à utiliser toutes ces
données pour essayer de voir quels sont
les modèles les plus crédibles les uns
par rapport aux autres
bon comme on verra ce calcul est
extrêmement compliquée du coup il n'est
pas faisable en pratique et du coup
ensuite le brésilien va chercher à
trouver des approximations de cette
formule deux pays''
typiquement environ un sous ensemble de
théories en pondérant par exemple un
sous ensemble de théories qui arrive à
bien gérer algorithmique mans
et peut-être même qu'il ne va pas
appliquer directement à la forme de
baisses il va peut-être avoir des
approximations de la forme de baisses
comme par exemple les calculs varient
nationale ou le maximum à poster rejet
tout ça on n'en parlera plus tard dans
cette série mais l'aspect qui est
vraiment intéressant sur lequel je veux
inciter dès à présent c'est que si le
balsa une puissance de calcul infini
alors il ya un calcul qu'il doit faire
il sait qu'il doit le faire et du coup
maintenant sachant qu'ils aient une
puissance de calcul fini il va vouloir
trouver des approximations de cet idéal
bézian qu'inaccessible que pour ceux qui
ont une puissance de calcul infinie et
j'espère qu'ils avaient aimé cet épisode
la prochaine fois on va plonger un peu
plus dans la méthode scientifique en
parlant de l'analyse statistique a plus
standard à savoir la méthode parp évalue
si vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à
la laquelle a commenté à la partager
pensez à vous abonner pour tom que
futurs épisodes dans ce petit peu à peu
leurs dons et j'espère que vous serez là
la prochaine fois nicolas mas du coup
pour voir si un traitement fonctionne
james linde va avoir une idée innovante
le 20 mai 2747 12 hommes d'équipage du
salisbury sont atteints des symptômes
classiques du scorbut fatigue
saignements des gencives déchaussement
des dents etc
il va leur mener une expérience sur une
expérience qu'on appellerait aujourd'hui
un essai clinique contrôlé quelques
jours après le début de son
expérimentation le résultat est sans
appel et je cite james lyng les deux qui
fait un usage des oranges et citrons
reçurent le soulagement le plus prompt
et le plus sensible un de ceux là fut en
état de remplir ses devoirs
au bout de six jours imparable
james lyne vient de faire une
démonstration très élégante que les
citrons et les oranges soigne bien le
scorbut en s'assurant que la seule
différence entre les différents groupes
de patients soit le traitement qui leur
donnent ils isolent les faits
spécifiques du traitement et il découvre
que c'est citron et orange
alors que au fond il n'a aucune
et du mécanisme biologique qui est
derrière aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle
c'est une méthodologie très similaires
qui sert à vérifier l'efficacité des
médicaments ou des interventions de
santé